le premier ministre rencontrera dès lors
le nouveau roi sas est prévue demain à 8
heures précises donc charme s'adressera
à la nation voilà c'est très mal on va
assister à ce qu'on appelle la
proclamation donc bah on va
officiellement là les chambres vont
officiellement reconnaître charles a
comme étant désormais lors leur nouveau
roi il régnera on le sait sous le nom de
charles iii ne s'en est jamais caché et
pendant ce temps là sera mis alors en
écosse l'opération unicorn que l'on
pourrait qualifier d' opération un peu
licorne qui va être le fait de rapatrier
la dépouille et il semblerait que ce
soit à bord du train lors de la claque
de l'halloween charles sera proclamé
officiellement que le lendemain oui
voilà oui voilà dix heures du matin oui
le même jour le parlement britannique
sera suspendu
ensuite sur nos demandes angie plus de
la dépouille de la reine devra reposer à
buckingham palace
alors elle l'a comme elle est décédée en
écosse il semblerait d'après les
informations que d'abord la dépouille
qui de balmoral qui est son château
privé sa résidence privée pour rejoindre
le palais officiels qui s'appelle
holyroodhouse donc le la dépouille va
quitter pour hollywood house ou voilà où
personne ne va dans le fond pouvoir se
recueillir pendant ce temps là une mais
ça va être donnée en la cathédrale saint
gilles qui est la plus grande chorale
décosse et quelques heures plus tard la
dépouille va être affrétés à bord du
train royal eh ben on le sait que depuis
1952 la locomotive royal n'a plus n'a
plus tracts et de voitures funèbre s'est
refait 70e pourtant vous avez dit que
c'était s'est adressé non ils ont
annoncé la mort d'elizabeth ii à toul
est président est-ce que sur emmanuel
m'accompagnait laisse que des anciens
présidents ou y aller ce que nicolas
sarkozy j'ai vu qu'ils avaient faim un
long hommage à elizabeth ii il va y
aller forcément le monde entier internet
se manifester maintenant il faut bien se
dire que c'est un tout petit peu plus de
2000 places que peut accueillir
westminster abbey donc on va pas pouvoir
accueillir tout le monde n'ont plus la
cote alors qu'en revanche pour le
couronnement selon l'ancien président
français c'est pas sûr qu'il soit ou non
le temps ça président français nous l'at
je ne pense pas parce qu'il ya tellement
tellement d'autorité qui doivent être
représentés et simplement on rappelle
que elizabeth ii était chef de l'église
ans l'icann ce qui fait aussi que
l'église doit être fortement
représentants qui aura que deux mille
personnes en 2000 invités plus ou mois
que 2000 même puisqu'on estime le corps
ecclésiastique donc l'ensemble des
archevêques des évêques sous la haute
autorité de l'archevêque de canterbury
et le primat de toute l'angleterre là
déjà ça va aussi être assez somptueux on
aura la pression à c'est quand même le
jour des obsèques tout est parfait mais
tout simplement ce que sera auront lieu
en l'abbaye de westminster oui voilà
deux minutes de silence ont suivi à
travers tout le royaume 2008 1 c'est
sain oui absolument et vous nous l'avez
dit est ce que c'est vrai que c'est
interpellé n'aurions-nous donc là partir
de demain donc quoi vous tenir là les
restaurants sont fermés mais je ne pense
pas que les restaurants vont être fermés
je crains vraiment les institutions
publiques vacances à hawaï non je ne
pense pas des restaurants uniquement le
jour des funérailles à quoi bon pour les
restaurants pour tout ce qui est privé
on rappelle quand même que l'angleterre
est en train de traverser une crise
économique sans précédent donc voilà
c'est pas non plus c'est pas non plus
vendable vous allez y aller vous nom en
angleterre non j'ai je fais le choix
j'ai fait le choix avec vos équipes de
leur série de rester ici pour voilà pour
pouvoir mieux commenté ici tout ce qui
se passe là bas parce qu'en même temps
la presse ne va pas vraiment être
autorisés non plus à pénétrer dans ces
lieux là même au sein même de l'abbaye
de westminster seule la bbc est vraiment
autorisé à retransmettre donc seul
vraiment quelques journalistes triés sur
le volet à créditer purement anglais
vont vraiment pouvoir approcher ces
lieux là emmanuel macron 10 jours en or
pour les funérailles sa c2 d'ores et
déjà convaincu on peut dire peut-être
aussi que la dépouille va être exposé en
tout cas le cercueil va être ouvert à la
population va être accessible ce serait
plus correct à la population entre 3 à 5
jours pendant vingt trois heures par
jour alors aujourd'hui au royaume uni
c'est
le peuple il est comment ils sont ici
c'est la reine elizabeth ii où elle va
aimer c'est au delà si elle allait adoré
et les iconiques elle est plus marilyn
que marilyn année est les célébrissimes
année elle est malade aurait vraiment
elizabeth ii allez adorer donc là c'est
sympa oui c'est une population qui est
en deuil qui est triste c'est ce
que charles arrive qu'au moment où ils
sont ils n'ont pas le choix c'est la
même heure sinon il aime beaucoup moi et
mais qu'ils arrêtent de maintenant il
est apprécié et célérité le prêt paris
du monde charel donc je n'ai aucun doute
sur le fait que ce sera un bon mois
maintenant les rapports entre mère et
fils on était voilà où le un certain
moment on sait que voilà il nie la bête
2 n'a pas toujours apprécié mais la
façon de charles surtout de s'exprimer
d'ailleurs